Besides the football
game, the halftime show.
And this year, of course, Taylor
the biggest buzz around
the Super Bowl was always
the commercials.
On Sunday,
the Foundation to Combat antisem
founded by New England Patriots
owner Robert Kraft, will air
a 32nd ad as part of its
stand up to Jewish hate campaign
Here's a behind the scenes
look at the moment
Kraft calls Martin Luther King J
Speechwriter Dr.
Clarence Jones
to tell him about their ad
about building bridges to combat
and the fact that it will be
featured in the Super Bowl.
Below
is this. Dr.
Clarence Jones apologizes for ca
This is Robert Kraft, my beloved
What a great honor.
No, it's.
It's my honor.
Well, let me tell you something.
We're going to run your
ad during the Super Bowl.
Oh, you know what?
You know
how to make a 93 year old man cr
Martin would have loved to.
Absolutely.
Get the chills listening to that
Joining me now from Las Vegas,
the site of the Super Bowl is
Robert Kraft.
Thank you so much for being here
Brill Building bridges to combat
That is a big part of what you d
You recently added $100 million
to the foundation
on top of the millions,
of course, that you put in to st
It's a huge part of your life's
Walk us through
how this Super Bowl ad came to b
and how you decided to feature D
Jones.
Well,
we part of the campaign of our f
is Stop All Hate in the country.
And it starts with Jewish hate
and then leads to every other gr
And we did a report that showed
if we created ads that educate
most Americans
who are great people,
that we need them to stand up
and not be silent
when they see something happenin
that's inappropriate to any an e
group, any religious group,
any gender issue, anything.
We have to stop.
Hate to keep the foundational va
of America strong.
And
when I had had a chance to see m
Jones, we spent about 3 hours to
and I saw the influence that he
on Martin Luther King, who
when I was in my early twenties,
I actually heard him
give the I Have a Dream speech.
And he was so articulate and so
and so such a bridge building pe
I needed we need more of that to
And one of the things that Dr.
Jones said to me
when we were in person, a said,
I love you, man,
because you've chosen to do this
And silence
is the biggest enemy of this cou
right now.
And you on
your own have chosen to do this.
And I said,
That's a great message
to give to all people.
But we have to have them
stand up and put back, you know.
And your message has always been
that hate is hate,
whether it's racism
against people of color or antis
I want to ask you,
because since the Hamas attack o
7th, Israel's retaliation,
the divide between blacks in Ame
and Jews seems to be wider.
Is that another reason for this
ad at this time in
this venue, the Super Bowl?
Definitely.
Look, we hope and believe over
200 million
people will wind up
seeing this in the end.
And you know,
what's happened, unfortunately,
with this issue with the Hamas a
it's been turned into something
you know, this is white oppresso
at work here.
And, you know,
62% of the people who have settl
Israel are people of color from
Africa, as well as Europe
and as a haven where people want
where for thousands of years
the history of
being in the country,
the history is there.
You know, Christ was born
in Bethlehem 2023 years ago.
And I think social media
are putting messaging out there
that's just improper.
So we have to correct it.
Well, before I let you go,
I know you are in Las Vegas
for the Super Bowl.
My in my house.
You also know that my son
is a huge Patriots fan.
He's not looking at the Super Bo
He's already
looking ahead to the next season
I have been instructed
by a certain 12 year
old to ask,
will you commit to drafting
Marvin Harrison Jr?
Well, he's very wise
and we're for the first time in
my ownership,
we've never drafted
as high as number three.
And he is definitely the person
if if we we would take a quarter
he has the highest ratings on hi
right now.
So your son is very wise,
but there's a lot that can happe
But you.
Yeah, he's got good
do whatever he's doing.
Fantasy basis is very smart.
Thank you, Mr. Kraft.
And more importantly,
thank you so much
for everything you do to raise a
for and of hate in this country
and try to bridge those divides.
Thank you.
You know, down to earth,
we have the greatest country in
and we have to keep this fabric
anywhere coming here
and living their dream.
And it's going to change
if we push back on this.
Thank you so much.
Be well. Have fun tomorrow or Su
Thank you. Thank you.